Mars its ancient crust is pockmarked
with craters craps and mounds they tell
the story of its past remnants of a
violent history some were formed by
impacts materials from space smashing
into the surface and leaving behind huge
craters others formed through erosion
and some like the monumental Olympus
Mons three times taller than Everest are
massive volcanoes but recently
scientists have found evidence of
volcanism on an even greater scale the
biggest explosions in the red planet's
history
we know that Mars has been modified by
volcanic eruptions throughout its
history but puzzlingly when we look at
its surface there are fewer volcanic
structures than we'd expect to
scientists turn their attention to the
Arabia terror a region of ancient crust
heavily scarred with impact craters it
was not however thought to be volcanic
one crater in particular caught their
eye
Eden Patera it didn't seem to fit with
their expectations for an impact crater
lacking defining features like a raised
rim a central Mound or a defined ejecta
pattern instead Eden Vitara bore a
striking resemblance to a structure seen
on earth called a caldera and calderas a
volcanic when you think of a volcano you
probably imagine a cone-shaped Mountain
spewing out lava and ash but if enough
material is ejected the volcano can
collapse in on itself forming a caldera
like this one the scientists think
they're looking at something similar on
Mars calderas are usually surrounded by
mounds of material boost out when the
volcano erupted but we don't see this
around eden Patera instead of oozing out
magma eden Patera must have exploded
with unimaginable force hurling billions
of tons of material thousands of
kilometres away and high into the
atmosphere spreading it across the whole
planet if this was a volcano it wasn't
just any volcano it was a supervolcano
this eruption of Mount st. Helens on
earth in 1980 ejected just over one
cubic kilometer of material super
volcanoes are capable of explosive
eruptions over a thousand times larger
the scientists discovered three
potential sites of extinct super
volcanoes but it's hard to know for sure
these volcanoes would have erupted over
three and a half billion years ago plus
super volcanic eruptions are so
devastating they destroy but of the
evidence that smaller volcanoes leave
behind and yet whilst hard to identify
the impact of super volcanic eruptions
is dramatic we know that in Earth's
history super volcanoes modified the
geology of entire continents and the
climate of the whole globe if there were
super volcanoes on Mars it could
revolutionize our understanding of the
early Martian atmosphere and explain
some of the big mysteries of Martian
geology like this bizarre region of
fretted terrain near the Arabia Tara the
scientists who did this research believe
that with more investigation we could
find more super volcanoes posing as
impact craters on the surface of the Red
Planet
but either way it seems that Mars is
ancient pastures even more violent than
we once thought
you